Hi, Marvel fans.
I am here with Victoria
Alonso, executive producer.
How are you doing?
- I'm great.
I'm excited.
Now Zendaya is coming, so
that's the party right there.
I mean, we got a party
going on here, too.
We had a--
Yes.
Today is a good day today.
Today is a good day.
We get to celebrate Spider-man,
one of my favorite characters.
Not the favorite, but
one of my favorites.
Nice save.
They're all my favorites.
Tonight is a big night.
This is the biggest Spider-man
film that we've seen today.
And the VFX are on
a whole other level.
Can you talk about
that just a little bit?
Just, there's just so
much that went into this.
You know, the
thing about working
on these things it just feels--
During the pandemic this
took far more effort
because we were not together.
And I think that what I longed
for is to be together again.
But we got it done thanks
to the 6,000 plus people
across the world.
So I thank every
single vendor facility,
human artist, and
family member that put
up with us working from home.
And hopefully you can
all go see it and shh.
Keep the secrets.
I thought you were
going to tell us a secret.
Shh.
I'll say no-- Are
you kidding me?
- I dunno.
- I'd rather--
I dunno.
--not saying anything.
All right.
Well what are you most excited
about with this film tonight?
I'm excited to see how people
react to something that's
been with us for so long.
So I'm just ready, ready for
all of you to know what I know.
OK, well I'm
ready for that, too.
How did you and your
team pull this off?
Well, you know, every
movie takes a lot of effort.
So it just was effort,
effort, effort.
And we have the
best team, you know.
Amy, Kevin, we have John
Watts, who's fantastic,
and we have a beautiful trio
in Zendaya and Tom and Jake.
And the friends are back.
They're back in town, so they
get to tell another story.
That's beautiful.
What does this
night mean to you?
I hope that this gift of
filmmaking that we put out
there to the world is
received with as much love
as we made it.
That made my heart
feel like mushy.
I love that.
Well I don't want to keep you.
Enjoy the rest of
your red carpet.
I look forward to
seeing the film.
Thank you.
Thank you for your support.
And if I don't see you anymore.
I think that's it for this year.
We have nine projects
that came this year.
Happy holidays.
We represented with
all of our hearts
so we'll see you after this.
We'll see you next year.
All right, see you.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]